une défaite rageante pour les jaune et
noir de plaisir après avoir mené pendant
une grande partie du match à l'extérieur
les illilois deuxième de nationale 3
n'ont pas réussi à conserver leur
avantage et s'incline contre leurs
poursuivants classement massy score
final 28 à 27 ans seulement de lui parce
que je pense qu'on avait toutes les
armes pour gagner le match
plongée au métier ils ont ils n'ont pas
paniqué quand il était à moins 4 ils
sont revenus petit à petit au score et à
et nous on a acheté des ballons un peu
trop bêtement là où on aura dû attendre
un peu plus travailler un peu plus
autour de thomas de leur défense enfin
une entame de match
irréprochable et derrière on donne
beaucoup beaucoup trop de ballons à
l'adversaire
un retournement de situation orchestrée
par le gardien de mastic justin porte à
l'homme clé de cette rencontre a mis en
échec les plaisirs en réalisant une
quinzaine d'arrêt pendant la partie sauf
était de la partie et j'irai pas dans le
registre de dire que le gardien n'est
pas bon bien au contraire
maintenant
faut être parfois capable de savoir lire
les modes de jeu des joueurs adverses et
dans ce registre là on a été très
mauvais on attirait toujours dans le
même mode de jeu et le gardien a fait
toutes ses parades dans les mêmes
intentions donc voilà c'est assez
frustrant
au classement ce résultat permet à massy
de revenir à hauteur des plaisirs hu à
la deuxième place du championnat avec 28
points chacun une défaite qui pourrait
remettre en cause les espoirs de montée
du promu yvelinois maintenant on a
attendu
je pense qu'on était un peu la surprise
du des matches aller de la phase aller
je pense que ce n'est pas pour rien que
c'est que moi si nous aligner quelques
quelques bons joueurs
parce que voilà maintenant il ya plus
d'effet de surprise donc on va être
attendu un peu partout et à nous de
faire en sorte d'élever notre niveau de
jeu les plaisirs roy devront élever leur
niveau de jeu dès leur prochain match
ils recevront le dimanche 4 mars le
leader saint polois cette fois-ci
défaite interdite pour ce choc